[Music]
okay great
so welcome to the last session of the
day this is one I've been looking
forward to how many well I'm not even
gonna ask how many people are familiar
with gdpr that's pretty much a given how
many are scared of GP gdpr okay
yeah probably rightfully so it seems
like some of the concern around GDP are
is the dead line which obviously has
passed we're now things arts how things
the stakes are higher but it also seems
like there's some lots not some there's
lots of discussion surrounding which
pieces need to be implemented to what
extent so I've heard lots and lots of
business conversations and legal
conversations around gdpr but I wanted
this to be a very practical technical
discussion about gdpr as in what
decisions are engineers and CTOs making
today to implement the first their first
versions of attempting to live up to
this standard because as engineers we
have to make super practical concrete
decisions so we're the ones that get to
wrestle with implementation of these
higher-level restrictions and and
policies so I invited the smartest
people I could find in Barcelona to talk
about this
they all have leadership positions at
interesting startups all handling
different kinds of data so I'm gonna
turn to my left and have them introduce
themselves
now cool thank you very much I'm Dave
I'm VP of engineering at well Burke so
before that I being involved in several
startups or CTO in this country and
outside and I think this topic is a
scary one of you mentioned so basically
the first time I knew about gdpr was
when our CFO came to our office and say
guys this thing is happening we need to
be careful is going to be cost us a lot
of money with a right and
okay apart from the finds anything about
what is going on there no idea so we
found ourselves the next six months
trying to find out what it's all about
so probably today we'll be sharing a bit
of our paints an experience about that
and hopefully would be funny and
constructive hello everyone I am Alberto
and I'm a CTO of body which is a startup
operating in the real estate field more
specifically in flat sharing so find the
perfect roommate we are active in Spain
and well in other european cities such
as London and Paris oh yeah I'm here to
talk about gdpr because our company has
been growing we are approaching the 1
million users and I think we it would be
a fun conversation hello this is Jordi
middle I'm currently co-founder of
learning games learning games is a
platform of educational games for kids
between 2 and 6 years old
and I'm the youngest one of them in
terms of company and also the smallest
one so I'm pretty sure I went through
less technical pains than them so my
view is that I do not only need to
comply with gdpr but if I want to
operate in the United States I need to
comply with copper which is children's
online protection whatever else but
basically it's a law that no one so what
it normally is since you don't want to
comply with it you don't collect data
from kids that's the safest way of
saying it so for us GDP are worse I
would say not that complicated because
we already took the decision of
collecting as few data as possible
having said so it's the same you get
someone at the office in our case was
the marketing so we're 12 so there are
no titles so some whoever is taking care
of marketing hey guys will crazy
deadline is here we don't comply with
anything we're going to jail
and then she put it well you two
co-founders are going to jail okay if we
don't if we don't solve those issues and
the first problem was what the fact do
we need to do does anyone have a clear
vision of really what is what was needed
and what is needed today because the
more I talk about it and read it the
less clear it is if we're doing things
right or all the things that need to be
done so so this is interesting so we
have someone dealing with data on
children someone dealing with your
passport information travel perks which
is formally Skyscanner
can I say that a lot yeah and we have
someone in the middle helping match you
with roommates so someone who could hurt
you in your sleep so these are these are
obviously significant all in their own
different way so Geordi you mentioned
that you might not have been as
concerned because you were already you
already took a minimal approach to the
capture of data
what were the other things that scared
you guys about like what was the biggest
initial concern when you heard about the
potential limitations of your data store
to existing data storage against the new
GDP our standard what was the biggest
freakout moment
well I wouldn't talk about being scared
rather our concern in terms of time and
effort so you do have a road map or you
know in start-up specially things have
to move very quickly you have random
investments and the in the middle of
these we get the GDP our it is true that
it has been around for a couple of years
before but you know but nobody really
understood what it meant and that and
this I think is a crucial point so the
point is that is the one of the typical
laws that has been that has been put in
place however I don't believe they
really have in the European Union a
board of tech people representing the
real world business case where they
would say okay so you're telling this
generic
concepts however how does this get
implemented do you know what are logs
you know the people store logs and they
do versioning and they have backups so
these things were the things where they
were concerning because there is not
state of the art nobody really knew how
to move and even law firms didn't
understand very well they understood the
law so law firms it's a great business
for them because they've been churning
charging companies here and there you
know people who have gone through one
two three different law firms because
they were not satisfied with the answer
and even though at the last one he
there's always things that you need to
cook we need to get to a compromise of
what is needed what can you do and as
you said where am I in this moment of my
company so how did you analyze your
systems first like what approach did you
take as a leader of a technical
organization what did you look at first
so basically was getting the team in a
room basically analyzing all the data we
were collecting storing and sending em
making sure a all the providers that
were receiving data were ok so basically
they were gdpr compliant we as they said
we are sending a minimum amount of data
needed not anymore not any less and
everything is designed according to the
specifications which obviously it was
not so so we had to reboot it was hard
time saying okay you guys contact with
partners you check the contracts do
other guys you analyze all the data
models things that were storing not only
database that's the easy one but logs
scattered around backups that are here
there and all the things that we are
collecting or not collecting and it was
pretty fun time making sure everything
is correct and still you make sure
everything is correct according to that
but because it's quite new you cannot
find any experts there is always this
moment of okay a moment of truth I'm not
sure if it's going to be okay or not
okay even if I put my best intentions
and everything so it's like you flip the
switch when you put the famous you send
the famous email
you put the famous screen what you need
to accept and after that is like fingers
crossed
which for the best we haven't closed so
far so so far so good
what surprised you about this data
inventory that you everyone has to
create some kind of a data inventory
otherwise you don't know where you are
right so I assume that was a slightly
complicated process or was a way easier
than you thought it would be to me it
was painful mainly because of this lack
of knowledge of are we doing the right
thing or not and basically we were
always designing with privacy and data
protection in mind but you never know if
you are missing the last bit especially
because we are dealing with sending data
to dozens of providers so you need to
make sure that doing the right thing
because maybe you are doing the right
thing then they are not so the weakest
point of the chain is the one a mother
so it's a bit stressful but also for us
it was pretty complicated issue we had
to check with all our providers to make
sure they were compliant in all third
parties and at the same time we now we
adopt something which is called privacy
by design so for any new system we will
design we will we will not adopt it so
that is the deal we are compliant we
will conceive it so that is the DPR comp
and it is a lot easier but when you
don't do that
you tend to for example dump everything
in a let's see in an s3 bucket so we
needed to really given they have an
inventory of what we were we're dumping
and how we could manage this data so
yeah it was pretty complicated I think
in our case one or one of the things
that as I said Coppa saved us a lot
because we had already taken chances or
decisions and second rehearsal if you've
gone over a thrown acquisition process
and you have to go through the due
diligence and if the one who is
acquiring you is a public company it's
even more complicated and fortunately
we've gone through that a couple of
times and I've always been very privacy
oriented which when you're a small you
tend the thing it doesn't it doesn't
make sense because it
it puts an overhead on top of what
you're doing that why should I be taking
all those caution or precautions I don't
know if I'm gonna be a life in six ten
twelve months this is for big
corporations who have security teams who
have but what is true is that if you
make this as part of your development
product development process it makes it
easier because you already know from the
beginning which is the other have you
put into your development while if you
have to do it when you've been running
your company for six seven five years
all the sudden you need to comply with a
lot of things that you're whomever is
acquiring you want you to do so it's
even more complicated so for us I would
say that we had different concerns
depending who you were talking in the
company so our marketing lady she was
very worried that consent was there from
from from our users and that every
single check who was wherever it was
needed but she was not that worried once
those screens and those flow she tested
them and we're okay and they were saying
good she don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing with that behind and so sorry how
you split that response every DT the
only way is if I a natural where you try
to do it but you have to review as you
said everything from how you tempted
data how you how you treat now you're
the data that you were processing for
your development environment there's a
lot of things that you had processes in
place but then you have to make a list
of all the things that are needed think
that respect that you have the resources
to cover them all and if not this is a
risk assessment so how bad it is if I
don't comply with any of it and how can
I live through that and and and keep
working in order to get closest to the
to the deadline as possible yeah there's
no question that compliance is a big
stick that can be used to wilt change
but checking the boxes doesn't
necessarily make your system more
private or more it's no no right so I
assume that
all of us being again technical people
here are concerned about the actual
secure implementation or meaningful
implementation of these rules I mean I
remember 20 years ago when you'd had you
had to be a super advanced developer to
even Hache your passwords in your
database
no one hashed their passwords in the
database now that's table stakes because
we have api's and libraries and a
culture and training and so do you think
that is that an example of where we'll
ultimately get to with the GDP our
implementations and as you're maybe not
converting the brownfield use case but
you're building greenfield stuff that
will just start to get a lot better
inherently and culturally about
implementing these things from scratch
is that possible or this is a too
complex for that yeah I think this falls
into the concept of privacy by design
and I think that's where we are going
but maybe let's get int into a practical
implementation maybe I could share ours
shortly basically we do have a
relational database admin database and
RDS ended up we are all in AWS so we
have my sequel and then we have logs
okay and we do need a lot of information
in the logs because we are using them
now not in real time but soon in real
time to improve our recommendation
system basically you are looking for a
flat mate and we recommend the most
suitable flat mate for you
so what we did so the point is ok for
GDP are you need to be able to delete
all the user data in all your database
and and data storage we have to be able
to provide the user with all the latter
they want and also that is this you have
to be able to upon request or from the
user to block is data from any select
insert update in case you need the data
maybe for but there is an investigation
ongoing but the user doesn't want you to
use the data it's a much complicated
case for me so practically speaking it's
not hyper complex when you are using a
cloud provider like AWS
to retrieve data or to even provide all
the data for example s3 buckets you put
on top of an s3 but this is our a one
over the example is very common on top
of an s3 bucket you put a Cena for
example in AWS so you can ask for all
the items all the data points that
contain a certain expression a certain
value and then you can run some ETL
processes okay so there is for example a
AWS glue so you can do this the problem
is how to scale so ideally do you know
Google takeout have you ever tried it if
you feel Google Google Wave it will take
out is basically a form where you write
your your yes you login and you can
retrieve all your data you can so that
would be ideally what everyone would
need the point is it requires a lot of
effort so now we do know with we can add
the hoc create scripts where we can
retrieve user data delete user data but
it is not scalable it's okay we have
almost a million user but we don't have
several petabytes right but in future
how do we ultimate Alice them how to
automate them and and let's see that's
an issue for us that we have an idea
maybe I will discuss later but what
about you guys what what do you do for
us it was a bit of a cultural change
because before you as already mentioned
you are sad ability to be fast you don't
you don't need to worry about the next
12-24 months you need to worry about the
next six months but then you reach to a
point and say okay don't worry about the
next six months if you don't comply you
and you won't get there okay you get it
serious so it's a bit of change
so when developers are working on
something they need to keep in mind
several rules it needs to be safe by
design so it needs to be you cannot lick
data isn't it to be fast simple but also
it is to contemplate this new dimension
of of gdpr so it's basically about
making a simple set of rules about what
is compliant what is not compliant
because usually if you check the
Wikipedia if you check what the lawyers
tell you like okay is this thing
ray is this the green or red so it's
basically making a set of rules that
anybody can understand
so we engineers are smart people so if
you put something that can be processed
logically you will understand it legal
language sometimes it's not so it's
basically okay is this thing compliant
or not in a way of things that I can
test and then work from there as they
say everything that is new needs to have
this mindset when it's designed and
implemented but basically if you get to
this set of rules that everybody shares
and understands is easy to get to
somewhere where you can make a parrot if
this is it compliant or not wear shoes
like Wooley I will talk to the lawyer
and they will see so it's not okay this
thing is what we agree is compliant this
thing is not so the same way you test
for your feature to be working as
expected to your specifications you
check is this compliant or not so it's a
bit of a change of the way how you
developed okay I like that question it
is can we foresee the appearance of
services appliance so even if you talk
to security guys they already are doing
things like that it's a matter of
customizing here and there but at the
end the problem is at the end solution
that we are that we built for ourselves
is in most cases it's not that unique
but we tend to think it's very unique
but at the end in software architecture
we don't invent those many things but
what is true is that you have people on
top of that and for me that's the most
what concerns me the most data systems
perfect that at the end we operate them
and we have people operating them and we
have people writing code on top of them
so as you said is how do you make sure
that that code that that infrastructure
lives by those standards and at the end
my way of thinking is by automation if
you the same thing that you were saying
if you write your unit test you're did
you should have tests for a lot of those
things and then you leave like
everything which is the percentage of
coverage of coverage you want to have
because 1% of coverage it's impossible
but have you had anyone asking for the
day
so I think yeah not many but there some
people were like I want that you know
the two or three guys that are coming
but yeah it was not super popular so
that I think that we will get more
educated into that and we as users are
gonna be asking for that much more in
the future
and not only us because we are geeks
I even think my wife who is a lawyer
will tend to do that one in the future
or or even my parent but nowadays if you
compromise as you were saying I have a
set of a scripts that I run manually
here and there whenever they are asked
maybe that's the right approach for this
moment to go because if you try to over
engineer and have a perfect system but
nobody runs it because you never asked
you're using the resources the wrong way
that's exactly the point I mean for
example in terms of future I personally
wouldn't know where to go in order to
implement gdpr
in a safe way I would copy Spotify but
if I as a great post explaining how they
encrypt everything in their database and
each user has one set of keys so what
does it mean it means that if you delete
the set of keys you can see you cannot
simply access the data from this user
even in backups in versioning so that's
a solution but it's complicated so okay
so if you're a small start-up and it's
growing at the moment if you can cope
with the request in a in a
semi-automatic way some Python scripts
or something why not do you have to
iterate batch processes over the night
yes can you do that yes it's ok it's ok
yeah so I want to talk about that
requirement because the export
requirement to me where user can get
their data that seems to me to be
required an advanced user and it's
somewhat of an advanced use case like
how many people have used Google takeout
not many but how many people email me
and say they want to be deleted from my
marketing database immediately way more
than asked for their data so let's talk
about the delete requirement because
that sends analytics teams into a frenzy
it sends DBAs or ops people you know
into a panic because as are these random
scripts that you're running against
every possible silo a data store or are
you implementing this in an application
layer logic where you have functions
that are written to smartly delete data
across disparate systems or what level
have you gone to to solve this problem
either in your application or in your
data layer like what does that look like
now you've talked you talked about
scripts Alberto what else has been done
so for example as we try to follow the
approach of not sending data unless
needed so if we are sending data to the
analytics if it can be anonymized
because I'm not going to join my
passport number something like here and
I'm not going to group by I don't do it
for the ones like logging where it's
just applying filters so we have an e lk
stack where we are having filters that
are removing any data it is not needed
plus we're having some software that is
running patterns to see just in case
something is broken so we try to have
this double checking on everything we do
the same thing where people want to be
deleted we have also the same approach
basically we delete them from the
database which is basically removing
anything that can trace back to the
individual plus our emailing system has
something that we basically we mark the
user in the database and in the email
system just in case for whatever reason
we don't delete them properly in one
system is on the others so we try to
deal out nullable foreign keys if a user
wants to be deleted can you retain all
the other order information or like how
do you solve that problem we yeah I mean
we don't have an olive-oil foreign keys
we do anonymize the data so maybe
instead of name surname phone we put
some anonymous like anonymous user we
put a string there or whatever but we
keep the relations because in our case
for example we have chat we have
bookings we would need to cascade
deleting cascade which is not doesn't
make sense and you might have sorry you
might have legal requirements like for
example we are booking on behalf of
people so we are legally required to
keep some data so I'm not going to a
spam you if you want me to delete but if
you are flying tomorrow
I'm sorry but I need to keep your data
because I was gonna flying so what scams
if there are frauds it happens and we
need to retain data in that case so that
that's the issue that which they tell
you physically delete which data they
you logically delete and we follow
something very similar which is by anime
anonymizing mostly everything in our
case we don't even so we have a dual
problem because I collect data from the
part from their parents and from the
children because at the end the parent
is was installing and paying for the
application and the children who is pain
and as you said we also keep that data
in order to recommend content we're
showing our kids and not only that
because I send report to the parents on
top of how they are performing and I
cannot also compare them to people alike
them so at the end is you need to start
checking which information can I use for
all that information and in case of
delete I have not had any requests for
data not even deletion but in theory
some of the test set that that we should
be capable of basically we're gonna
anonymize data I'll live with it and you
need to keep it as long as different
laws involving and request you to do so
so we want to open it up to audience
questions in the next couple minutes so
be thinking about the questions you you
might want to ask but before we get
there so let's talk about logging let's
talk about logging or backups you you
pick
how has your logging or backup strategy
changed with this requirement so the
thing honestly speaking we have a plan
but it didn't happen yet but the point
is if we are deleting accounts or we are
just if we are removing users we have to
keep a list of those users so in case of
disaster recovery
it can happen it could happen at a food
for a few minutes because of you know
business requirements you you restore
I'll back up with that data those data
but then you we will we will run the
list again through an entire system
that's what you do that's what if you
encrypt it that's the idea like Spotify
does this problem is already solved we
do we do something very similar so we're
trying to keep our backup a strategy is
similar to what we have before and a
process that ranting in theory in
parallel to that restoration process to
try to remove that data that should not
be available I have concerns that for a
given moment you might end up allowing
access to some data that should not be I
can live with that risk today yeah we
also try to keep the backup as as near
to the to the last moment so basically
we use we are built on top of AWS will
use RDS which the most of you know the
backup and the back in time feature that
they have is amazing you can go back in
time like two minutes before the
disaster happen to me that I dropped a
table actually was a database in
production so you need to Joel oh so
basically you go back in time and it's
fine and this thing also reduces the
risk of loosing these data that was
anonymized so you are keeping the
backups every month maybe in the last
month some people wanted to be removed
from the database but in if you can have
this minute resolution but apart from
that as we also keep the request to be
deleted or request to be changed in an
additional database we create sender
stickers for that just in case of
loosing that we will be able to recover
what is missing from the Delta that is
missing from the last backup to the to
the current moment in time I mean the
the whole thing I in the end I think
just in general that
if someone told me today they feel
they're fully complying gdpr
and they're storing logs they're having
backups I would kind of not believe them
yet so that's it but that's why we are
sharing our experience really hands-on
like okay we do believe we are compliant
lawyers don't really understand what it
means I understand the low button is
okay
I just mechanics panel of what does mix
panel what do they don't understand so
what I do believe is that GDP are now is
an active law I believe that a big
company will get a huge fine soon so
that they will show that Jana is they're
really gonna enforce it and also given
the president we will be able to assess
what we have to do or not so basically
what can you defend in court we don't
know yet I mean of course we're trying
to be compliant but it's what generic
that you could be liable for anything
that's the point so you use the good
sense and let's see let's see the first
there will be trials there let's see
what's happening there and I think it
will be a big company as an example that
doesn't comply so why do you think
everyone just doesn't encrypt all the
data in the database that's a lot of
questions but let's talk about it anyway
I think that we don't do it because we
didn't design it that way from the
beginning and talking about more or less
mature companies now you need to go and
change first your database are you
capable of doing that hot and not going
down for a while with your business
cannot afford check on all the processes
that you already have from building code
to deploy into backups to everything so
if you had unlimited resources which no
one has not even Google you might
consider it but if you have not done it
that way from the beginning
I don't think you have the resources to
do that even if you would like to do it
so you live with what yeah you're a
slave of the decisions you took years
ago so some of those things trying to do
it afterwards it's merely impossible but
also starts a startup and MVP
okay I encrypt with this you a set of
key for each one of the users the
database you just look for your seed
round then the need goes fast you want
you get to series a then you look for a
CSV so it would be I think it would be
big design up front maybe over
architecture for a company that doesn't
know where it's going in a month to
really designer that there is with the
encryption keys and it's complicated for
us we went from as I said an MVP and
then we're finding okay things that you
need to encrypt Craig cards of course
PCI you take basically shut down the
business same thing with passport which
is has a similar sensitivity which
basically we encrypt only the passports
but all the rest as I say we need to be
also conscious of the cost risk so we
make the risk assessment so yeah
encrypting everything depends on the
level if you do it at data base level
for example might give you a false sense
of security
yeah my son engineers won't be able to
access this thing but anybody who can
query your database will so it's about
basically balancing which is risk this
benefit of you ran a risk model or risk
analysis on all the different types of
data in your platform and you decided
based on that priority which which to
spend more like common sense we say okay
if we we might be losing the pair name
email for example that's criticality X
we might be losing Craig card that's why
and we might be losing passport that's
it so basically we say what is in a
scope or not on a scope because all wise
you're also adding a lot of complexity
to your development meaning you're going
in slow maybe you have the safest
service in the world that nobody's using
so there's not the point for companies
like ours
mmm-hmm let's take a question from the
audience
anyone we have a microphone coming
hi I was wondering how you guys have
dealt with the so for us data scientists
love as much day as they can possibly
get their hands on how you guys have
dealt with sort of gdpr in that sense
and still sort of allowing them to
access data in certain ways so our
solution has been essentially to sort of
pseudo anonymize anything into the data
like as it were and then if there is a
specific requirement sort of have a risk
analysis on that and then allow sort of
certain people to access to it but it's
kind of a wider thing of how do you know
strangle your own data science projects
I just wondering what your solutions
were that's that's a great question
basically how do you give people the
tools so they can make their job without
being being completely open basic at
least in in my company what we do is
whatever you would you require will be
given to you so basically if you have a
point where you need to access passports
because you need to I don't know run an
analysis on how the the correlation
between the passport number I'm making
it up with the possibility to fly
somewhere yeah why not
so basically you will be do will be put
inside the scope and then you will be
part of the process because if you need
the data I'm not going to tell you no
you don't need that to lose your job at
the same time you need to balance this
thing with everything is open for
everybody which is not good this is not
a policy we follow why because maybe you
don't need it and it's something bad for
you because you are getting an extra
responsibility that you can need so it
will be basically sitting down with you
and deciding what do you need why do you
need it because maybe you can get it
from somewhere else or maybe the data
can be anonymous or pseudonymous
and it would be good for you but of
course you need to in order to perform
your job you need to get some data so of
course you need to get access to it so
as a matter of course are you pre
anonymizing and pre aggregating more
data than you used to before just to
sort of prepare for these analytics use
cases or the data being deleted out from
underneath you has that changed the way
you're planning your analyst
in my case of course before we were like
happier in terms of okay let's send this
thing to the locks just in case we need
to recover it you will be it would be
easier sure it's easier everything is
open but then you need to face the child
the problems of okay for whatever reason
somebody left this bucket open happen to
basically most of the people so what
happens now if you leave bucket open
with data that is known in minds of
children only mites fantastic they will
know how many trips you could eat per
day so you are losing business metrics
it's a problem for the company if you
lose it for a user is a big it's a big
deal so yeah for us before it was like
okay happy everybody everybody in this
world is good and they're not going to
do anything wrong with the data the
buckets can be open but you find that
the reality it's not like this oh yeah
in our case yes we we don't pray
anonymize but we are very careful
careful on what we store now before we
were like dumping everything and you
know it's it's a matter of fact we did
that so we found out that we were
throwing more trash to the logs than we
wanted while our data or data storage in
terms of databases was much more
automated and anonymized than what we
were doing with the logs and one of the
things we found out is we should run the
same policies with one way or the other
and then the main reason was we don't
have an Operations team we are 12 people
and we do basically a little bit of
everything we have two people
concentrated on data so they did it
better from the beginning and as we were
reviewing [ __ ] those locks of data that
should not be here that's an unintended
benefit right if it's helped turn your
data swamp into a data Lake it's for
sure I mean it had well it helped or it
forced and those days when you have 10
people and you have to decay two people
to that rather than growing up the
product you don't feel that happy but at
the end since we need to comply with the
law let's write it the best and fastest
possible just getting back to your
question because I think it's very
relevant
long story short we do have six people
in our data team and we trust them
professionally and legally we have NDA's
so I don't see why they cannot access
the data they need you know so they can
do that what we don't do is providing
everyone access when it's requested and
there is a reason we give access also
AWS is very good withdrawals you know so
so we try to enforce it more and more
and that's the idea but I don't see any
issue wire that scientists cannot access
everything in a database okay another
question
hi could you talk a bit more about your
data anonymization techniques because
well with certain with where is with the
large amount of data we collect even
just removing a name and email address
might not be sufficient and just how you
go about it you generate pseudo names
spoof the GPS data just curious what it
in a nutshell when someone wants to
delete their data in the RDS in the
relational database we look for the for
the user and we are naanum eyes all the
fields basically all the attributes
which are personal how do we assess that
more or less we know it can be emailed
for if you for example look at Google
Analytics okay which is aggregated you
will say okay that is gender there is 8
so maybe this I can leave okay
but we anonymize fully name surname for
email and in the logs what we are doing
right now because we don't have any
infrastructure we just delete you know
we just delete the log every instance
where this user ID appears out so I'm
sure I comply surely we could run some
ETL processes to to just change
something without deleting the log but
at the moment we do that yeah in our
case pretty much and set up the only
thing that is a slightly different is
that when we send the data to the logs
for example to the case of the logs we
already don't care about anything that
is personal there mostly we want to know
person X went from A to B so we are not
storing anything that is sensitive to
that person is xxx at home mail so we
are able to track by some other means
that are not targeting to the person
that makes our lives easier if we had to
go through all the indexes and then find
this data and then delete it it will be
as you mentioned pretty painful because
if we are talking about we are still
small we're in the gigabytes we are not
stealing the terabytes but if if you
grow to like the previous presentation
they were in Para byte so that would be
not nobody-nobody feasible so basically
what we do is not send it there if you
minute and then in the places where it
is needed to be store like is the
database or any data store that is like
this having a fast way of deleting this
thing if we had to go through a locks
and la 10th tons of locks and delete is
just not feasible so you are going to
end up leaking some data not much to
that I think that it is pretty similar
to to what we do as I said we found out
that we were not doing properly logs and
what we do in logs is and have very
little information about my users I have
the email of the Father the nickname
that he puts to the children account and
the 8th so from personal point of view I
have a very restricted data set that I
need to deal with and if I had to choose
email is my first worry because the
nickname you put to your children's
account could be not even personal so
I'm more worried about the email and the
H in gender then than anything else and
they have so little I treat those four
values more or less the same way
what about third-party data sources
um it's not even dealing with
significant amounts of third-party data
and have you had to jump through hoops
there you know I don't
so you mean sending or receiving data
from third part I was taking receiving
okay now I'm mostly sending because
actually what we do is book on behalf of
people with syrup artists what we said
basically receiving is the end user the
ones is the origin of data now in this
case I mean in case of third party
parties we we do send and we try to send
this as less as possible events for
example but events but they are written
on mais so we are not concerned so much
about that we are although even though
we are we are storing in our logs more
important more personal data may be the
new guys if I look for a flat in in New
York City we will know the geo location
where someone looks for that's why I
delete the lines there in case it's
needed
it's more complicated for us we need to
store logs with more data it's like
another question
I heard myself back to the question
about like the system design like I
think like from what you said is like
now if you already have the system that
run in production it probably
impractical to chant anything now but
say that if you decisis them from
scratch like similar to password like
yeah
twenty Yoko no one has the password but
like this day we kind of learn and like
if you design a new system today do you
have like any good practice or anything
that you would do differently in our
case at least what I will do is
different if I can go back in time and
now had the knowledge I will be well you
need to treat the date nature like being
able to access change and modify export
as features so the same way you have a
feature for looking a fly from A to B
you should be able to have a feature
that is the user connects park is data
and this thing is translated not only in
how you implement it is this needs to be
tested so in case somebody breaks they
called you you don't have for whatever
reason a leak of data or user not able
to export if you have the Pioche keeping
this thing in mind when you design the
features so to me this needs to be a
first-class citizen when you design the
system when you implement this when you
monitor all this kind of things and not
just something you do because you are
going to get fined then the reality is
that we had the system that we had so we
had to basically patch this thing you
know how it is
but if I had this power of going back in
time I will treat this thing as
first-class citizen since day one I just
thought for example without thinking
about making time I think that privacy
by design or designing a system or a
micro service that is fully compliant
with gdpr
to do so you know you you will need to
to really think about how you store data
the data base and whether it is relation
relational and in these regards my own
experience my guess would be if I had to
design a micro service now but first of
all I would design it in a way that
already conceiving all the objects all
the elements in a way that they can be
retrieved very easily like in cascade or
with relation very clear but what would
what I would do would be investing in
graph databases neo4j or AWS Neptune I
think that this could be a nice idea
okay because through a node you can
iterate and get to other nodes and it
would make retable very much easier this
would be something I would explore and I
would explore it because it's powerful
it's fast performant and it would
fulfill the the need I have of
retrieving data quicker and I wouldn't
have thought of this before so this
changes the paradigm hence why privacy
by design would be a test that we do I
think that I would make the whole
company aware of what that means for the
company and how it should be implemented
because it's not only us who are dealing
with that data and I go back to my point
in my previous point it's all the
employees that have access to that data
and as you girl you put more conscious
or unconscious you're more worried and
who access what and when when you're a
smaller you don't care more or less
everyone has access to 100% of the data
but if you have these in mind from the
beginning is how your company should
operate with that data internally and
externally because as you said how do I
send and I retrieve that that
information take an assessment do your
own assessment how worries the limit
where you want to go and from there have
it as a clear rule for every for every
development that you're doing and comply
with it you're from an economic
standpoint GTRs definitely changed the
economics surrounding not just the
opportunity of today the data but the
potential risk of storing it so we
finally have a flip side of the of the
opportunity cost right so that's
interesting to see and I think companies
and teams will have to adjust to that as
well what's the economic
and what's the downside potentially of
the risk of storing the state of another
question
Christine hi so you guys are talking
very specifically about you know it's
been very personal data like we're
talking mean name email passport number
but you're also collecting anecdotal
data about all of these people where
they travel where they're looking for
apartments how they're interacting with
your games how do you handle this data
which could be used even if you're
scrubbing their email that could still
be used if you have enough points to
identify a person as a natural human
being which is also part of GDP our
compliance how are you guys thinking
about building this in your systems well
still being able to give your data
scientists what they need these hence
why we are waiting for presidents and
see what was gonna happen but I do think
that we can work in an aggregate level
more and more so this can be done but uh
well I it's it it's complicated I would
say that GDP are takes into account one
thing which is called legitimate use and
the best interpretation of this term is
that that that is going to be defined by
a judge it's it's tricky but it is my
understanding that if I want to provide
our users a product and I need certain
data because I have alerts so I need to
store where they're looking for for
example then the moment they agree to
use my application my platform they
implicitly agree to legitimate use where
I ask for explicit agreement is
marketing email sending to third parties
this was also confirmed by our lawyer so
the legitimate use so it's not so strict
in that in those regards but who knows
if there was someone suing us how would
it we would have to explain why we
really need this data I'm sure we could
wean but still is tricky there is not a
table that they spin what's legitimate
or not it depends on the product yeah I
totally share because for us we had the
same problem it's like we went to the
lawyer's say we want to store ABCD we're
going to protect this with that this
with the other thing is it good they say
okay do you really need this data to
provide the service or are just storing
it just in case to do some predictions
or to sell it to somebody else no no we
need that because if we I don't know
your name where are you going from and
where do you want to stay I cannot
provide my service I might be booking
for somebody else so for us it's
something as simple as that
but yeah at the same time even if there
is not the typical a name passport top
all that can identify person I fully
agree that they need to be treated as
sensitive sensitive data because they
can identify where you are who you are
even if it's not exactly you they can
narrow down the search to somebody who
is quite a specific so we actually even
if it's not like first class first class
like passport thing clearly I agree that
they we should give this thing a
consideration of being sensitive data
the GPS might be not knowing who you are
but hey this is the coordinate there's
one guy there is this guy so one of the
things we did which we had a big debate
was we are now asking our users if we
want they want us to collect the data
and use it for providing a better
experience in the application and they
can opt out well in fact they have to
obtain
and the main issue is I have different
paths for different ages with different
games and difficulties but that changes
because I know how well or bad are you
playing and I have of course all the
data from users similars or not to you
and that helps me provide a better
experience but hey you don't want your
data to be used neither to enrich third
party kids nor even to benefit up to you
and and that was changed for us because
in the beginning it was easy with all
your queries or or and processor build
one way now I have to think that this
piece of data that I'm all the events
and everything I'm collecting has to be
marked on a way then I don't have to
create it and I don't make it go all the
way through the our recommendation
systems and so mmm in generally we don't
have many users that have decided not to
do it but because it's part of what we
sell as us as the good things we do but
we need to do it for our users and then
for our data science guys that they need
to be capable of not dealing with that
top of the on top of that there is the
retention period nobody tells you what
is your retention period so they could
tell me yeah I found you users find you
find the room on in an average of 48
hours while you're storing logs for 12
months ok so I argue that I need this
data because we booking system know if
there is a fraud some credit cards allow
you to to dispute the the charge up to
12 months after fair enough then in my
retention period has to be literally
speaking twelve months at the least this
is my own assumption we talk to our
lawyers but there is no we feel we are
compliant and we are I'm sure that is us
it's not something we already did and
it's done it's a continuous process we
are learning where that's what that's
why we discuss with other colleagues and
in these regards but yeah so it's all
subject to interpretation at the end we
have time for one more question
and so you talked about change of
culture and my question is to what
extent you feel that there was actually
a change of culture or was it more like
a moral panic that was caused by the
media and the deadline of May and the
very high fines why I'm saying that is
because there is a new regulation coming
up they privacy regulation and to what
extent do you think the developers are
aware of this I didn't hear very well
what was the last part of my shoes were
hard to hear a bit okay so to what
extent do you feel that there is has
been a change of culture or was it like
a moral panic that was caused by the
deadlines the fine and the media and the
reason is because I'm asking is because
there is a new regulation coming up they
privacy regulation okay Margaret I think
that panic changed culture so what you
mentioned I think is comparable so you
see a problem you need to face it you
sink or swim so we had to swim and by
swimming you change all cultures say
okay now the rules are not the same we
change the rules we need to operate
we're playing a different game now so
what was okay before which is okay it's
secure I'm not leaking data but okay if
the user wants the his data I don't know
I might be sharing it with third parties
I might be selling it to a book and know
now is different so he's I think that it
was the carrot and this and the stick so
I think they were they were really good
applying the stick so the first thing we
knew is like the sanctions that were
behind that four percent 20 million this
is big number so say okay whatever it's
bigger which is even more enforcing that
so this thing makes you realise that you
need to change your culture it's like
okay guys now we're playing this new
game that is whatever we did before plus
one and this plus one is we need to play
GDP our and and I think it was a led to
be because if you don't have this let's
say in quote my words incentives
probably the change will be organic with
some people coming and say you know what
guys we need to respect the user which
is which is pretty pretty honest thing
but these compared with okay
these are the numbers this is what's
going to happen is the message is much
more stronger so basically we use this
light fear in a good way to basically
say okay guys there's no discussion
about that it's not about being good or
about being honest that is good but it's
also if you don't get that don't worry
you will get this number so it was a no
brainer you can go to any Board of
meeting and say we are going to do this
thing now because this is the
consequence it is like no but we can
prioritize this feature no no no feature
this is the thing we need to do or we're
going to die so this is a pretty good
motivational tool so for us it was even
a good thing because you don't need to
explain anybody so you go to the CFO
they get it the CEO they get it
everybody gets this thing so it's a it
was a pretty good thing because you put
everybody on the same framework and
basically everybody knows 20 millions oh
great
so guys last question was anything that
you just said for the last 45 minutes
could that be characterized as legal
advice no no it does any place I don't
know what legal means so excellent
excellent
great thank you it's good man
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you